we often hear about the sunni-shia
divide today in media coverage about
conflict or political situations in the
Middle East one sort of gets the
impression of a perpetual war between
two branches of Islam and often with
very little nuance when these branches
are explained or are talked about by
experts or journalists war in videos
here on YouTube
they often present a simplified version
of the historical and contemporary
differences often boiling it down to an
event that happened after the death of
Muhammad but as you might expect at this
point it is a lot more complicated than
this so what are the differences between
the Shia and the Sunni and how did they
come about
[Music]
so as you may have heard the story
begins arguably with the death of the
Prophet Muhammad in 632 ad this event
sort of sent shockwaves through the
entire community and immediately this
started discussions on who should
succeed him there was one group one camp
who believed that his close friend abu
bakr should be the first halifa or
caliph but not everyone agreed there was
another group who believed that his
cousin and son-in-law Ali was the
rightful heir
the first group who favored Abu Bakr
sort of won this argument and he became
the first in a line of four so-called
rightly guided caliphs followed by Omar
Othman and eventually Ali himself and
who were all elected by a kind of semi
democratic process you could say this
first group who favored Abu Bakr we
could call the proto Sunnis it is this
group who would later become the Sunni
the other group of favourite Ali was
often called the Shia Ali which means
the party of Ali and this is where the
word Shia
comes from this is usually where the
story ends for a lot of people that this
divide is simply a difference in the
succession of Muhammad and that it kind
of ends there but there's a lot more to
this story over the following decades
and centuries there would be great
conflicts of authority who should lead
the Muslim community we can't really
talk about a Sunni versus Shia conflict
here because these two distinct groups
hadn't even emerged yet in that sense
there were many proto Sunni groups like
the umayyad and abbasid dynasties that
you've probably heard of and many other
that would compete for who should be the
rightful leader there were also the
descendants of Muhammad and Ali the Shia
who favored or sort of their idea was
that the rightful leader of the Muslim
community should belong exclusively to
the prophet's family his descendants in
the line of ali to the shia ali was the
first so-called imam both a worldly and
spiritual successor to Muhammad who had
been given the secrets to understand and
interpret the religion correctly after
Ali there is thus a line of
mom's that will succeed him as as Imams
as leaders which begins with his son
Hasan and then Hussein now Husein
started a kind of revolt against the
earlier Maya dynasty and was very
famously martyred and killed by Umayyad
forces in Karbala this is a very
important event to Shia and Muslims and
is commemorated every year in a festival
or are they called Ashura after his
saying his son became the next Imam and
then his son and then his son and so on
most of these Imams favored a kind of
quietest approach to generalize living
somewhat secluded lives with a group of
followers despite often being persecuted
by the Umayyad and later Abbasid caliphs
as a threat to their leadership the
proto Sunnis in later Sunnis were led by
the caliphs leaders who had mostly
worldly secular power although some of
the other caleb's did call themselves
imams - and did with significant
religious authority as many of you know
these includes the caliphs of the
dynasty as I mentioned like the umayyad
and abbasid empires now because things
insist on always being complicated the
Shia so-called branch isn't a homogenous
group either in fact they're divided in
many branches of their own already by
the fifth Imam or after the fourth there
appeared as a conflict of succession on
who the next Imam should be there was
one group who favored a guy called
Isaiah they've been Ali who became the
these IEDs the Sayyidi Shia or the also
known as the five are Shia and these are
still alive today in makeups a
significant portion of the population in
Yemen and then while later there
appeared another conflict of succession
in the first sort of line by the fifth
or sixth depend on your asking mom jafar
as-sadiq there were some who favored his
oldest son a smile even Jaffa who became
known as the is smile ease or seven or
Shias which is the second largest group
of Shiites today another faction rather
viewed his younger son Musa al-qasim to
be the rightful successor and these
became known as the if Natasha or
Twelver Shia sometimes also called the
Imam is Shia and this is this is the
largest group today it is the twelve or
former shiism that is dominant in Iran
today and it's the state religion of
Iran
the smiley is on the other hand is quite
complicated too they eventually
established the Fatimid dynasty and
further developed into more branches the
Nazari and mas tally is my lease the
former is the largest of these and it's
the only group of Shia who still have a
living Imam in Agha Khan the fourth the
latter group is represented by a group
called the Boris who exists primarily in
India today my reason for retelling this
general history is to point out that the
Shia is not a homogenous group and
neither are the Sunnis we shouldn't
therefore a view history as this kind of
clear dichotomy between these two Sunni
versus Shia in some kind of conflict
because this divided these this grouping
didn't exist historically in the way
that we conceive of it today
ok so historical facts aside we should
also recognize that since the Sunni and
Shia often had completely different
ideas about Authority this of course
affected their own sort of doctrines and
ideas too not only was this sort of
divided political early on it also
eventually became philosophical
theological and legalistic because the
Shia and Sunni viewed different
companions of Muhammad as more or less
trustworthy this also affected greatly
the the transmission of hadith the
stories about the prophet and his
companions so the Sunni and Shia often
used different collections of hadith
from each other which is also the basis
of much Islamic law and ritual not only
that but the Shias also view the hadith
of the Imams as authoritative and not
just those of Muhammad and these hadith
SAR also frequently used in legal
matters as well as time went by
theological differences appeared to
generally one can say that the more
rationalistic Lee based theological
school of the Motta's ala which
eventually became a minority in the
Sunni world was adopted to a much larger
degree by the Shiites especially by the
twelve or anxiety branches then what
does Allah favored a more metaphorical
and allegorical reading of Scripture and
had a more transcendent view of God
without any anthropomorphic features for
example what does Allah school was quite
popular early on for the Sunnis as well
but soon thereafter it lost its
prominence to another school called
Arshad ISM a more literalist approach
which is still the mainstream today the
Smyly is in turn went in their own
direction heavily inspired by new
platonic philosophy their theology is
very unique in this context having very
different ideas about revelation and
metaphysics for example and features
many esoteric aspects when it comes to
question of thick or jurisprudence there
are differences here too while the
Sunnis eventually developed to gradually
discard things like personal rational
efforts by the jurist in favor of the
revealed sources like the Quran hadith
and analogy and and so on the Shia
market a generally has maintained the
importance of something called a jihad
which could be translated as personal
interpretation or personal efforts to
interpret while they didn't like things
like analogy as much as the Sunnis did
when talking about the Sunni world that
is often stated that the door to each D
had closed around the Year 1000 and this
of course isn't true at all since the
people still kept interpreting and are
still interpreting today but that's a
subject for another video we should
remember that these are huge
generalizations and that I'm speaking
primarily from a historical perspective
in fact the concept HD HUD has very much
resurfaced in the Sunni world especially
in the last two centuries with the
emergence of certain reform movements
like what is often called Islamic
modernism in which people have started
to reinterpret and use HD had again to
reinterpret the original sources like
the Quran which has led to everything
from Islamic feminism to al-qaeda so the
Sunni schools of law the mother hubs
which are the Hanafi the Shafi the
Maliki and the Hanbali are independent
and difference from the various Shia
schools the the the 12er school of
jurisprudence is often referred to as
the Joffrey school the Sayyidi school is
called the Zion school and these smileys
have the Smyly school very simple of
course these Smiley's at least the in
the Saudis mildly still have a living
Imam which means that he still has the
highest authority and last word when it
comes to interpreting the Quran and
derive or adapt its lost to current
society in fact this is one of the main
doctrines of Shiism the Shia Imams are
not simply worldly leaders of the Muslim
community they are the spiritual leaders
and authority as well it is thought that
Ali was given the inner secrets to
interpret the Quran a spiritual wisdom
that he handed o
to the next Imam who handed it over to
the next and so on to the Shia the Koran
isn't complete in that sense but must
always be interpreted and understood by
the living Imams the descendants of the
Prophet himself the Sunnis on the other
hand while the early caliphs did have
some authority over religious matters
and the law this authority eventually
fizzled out and they became more secular
leaders religious matters then being
dealt with by groups of jurists
theologians and to some degree Sufis
Sufi sheiks we should remember to avoid
viewing this divine as some to clear
factions that are at perpetual war or
something the war conflicts of course
and the minority group was often
persecuted and oppressed by the majority
these are just a few of the multitude of
different perspectives and ideas that
existed within the larger Muslim
community many Sunnis were inspired by
Shias and vice-versa I would argue that
they didn't appear a clear Sunni versus
Shia dichotomy as we think of it today
until the rise of the so called
gunpowder empires in the early modern
period
let us let's say between the 16th and
18th or 19th centuries so on the one
hand we had the Ottoman Empire who ruled
large portions of the Middle East from
Istanbul were predominantly Sunni and
then on the other hand we had what is in
modern Iran the Safavid Empire whose
state religion was 12 or Shiism and so
here for the first time we have two
empires one who is very clearly Sunni
and the other Shia and who were not
always on the best of terms these
empires and the culture and religion
practice there were often very distinct
from each other to the point that they
can sometimes feel like completely
different religions for example in XI
Safavid Empire Sufism began to be viewed
in a very suspicious light many of the
jurists of the Safavid Empire were very
opposed to Sufism and it was often
persecuted which is especially weird
since the the Safavids were founded by
and named after a Sufi order the
Safavieh and this stands in stark
contrast to the two other Sunni empires
the ottomans and the Mughals both in
which Sufism flourished this negative
stance towards Sufism that started
during the Safavid dynasty has left its
mark even to
as many of the Sufi orders in Iran like
the new Mutulu he order is severely
oppressed still today so even though the
gunpowder empires don't exist anymore
its effect can very much still be felt
the lands that were ruled by Ottoman and
Mughal empires are still dominated by
Sunnis in terms of population in
contrast Iran and the larger Persian
region has a majority of Shiites with
emergence of the nation-state system
these conflicts aren't as clear as they
were back then although there clearly
are still tensions as we can see today
in the region that's what is important
to remember is that the big Shia Sunni
tension that we see today isn't that old
either it has really only become worse
in the last 70 years or so with the
increase of divisive politics in the
Middle East and the subsequent spread of
fundamentalist groups also important to
remember is that a lot of groups and
religious leaders from both sides of the
spectrum are working hard today to
establish a religious unity between
these two groups and solidarity there's
a lot of examples of this kind of
syncretism both in the contemporary
world and also historically to conclude
the difference between the Sunni and
Shia are not simply a question of the
succession after Muhammad this initial
division led to many other developing
distinctions between the two they often
differ on how the Quran should be
interpreted or even conceived they have
different views and authority their
theologies have developed in different
directions they often use different
collections of hadith by different
narrators and thus the loss or their
Sharia and rituals often differ they
celebrate distinct holidays like the
Ashura in in the case of the Shia the
doctrines of the Imams is also a
significant distinction as is the more
prominent focus on top wheel and Shiism
and as we've seen the Shia themselves
are also divided into multiple branches
that are often very distinct from each
other as well as are the many branches
within Sunni ISM there are even
differences in very central sort of
ideas and concepts like the so called
five pillars of Islam while the Sunnis
and twelvers have five pillars these
smileys actually have seven so as you
can see the differences are often much
larger and significant than we are led
to believe but at the same time and as
I've stated multiple times in this video
we should also avoid drawing to clear a
dichotomy between these two groups as if
they were like the Catholic or
docks churches in medieval times or
these two branches that are constantly
at perpetual war instead history has
shown a complicated myriad of schools
and ideas that have sometimes been in
opposition to each other there have been
periods in history like right now or
during the gunpowder empires where the
division appears much more prominent and
other periods and places where it hasn't
been everything I've said in this video
is of course generalizations too but I
hope I've given you a bit a more nuanced
and complex view of these two movements
within Islam let me know what you think
and and please correct me if I've made
any serious mistakes I'll see you next
time
[Music]
you